ja und sie drehte neben ihrem job als
zugbegleiterin sexvideos in
regionalzügen als sogenannte porno
schaffnerin gelangte die reserve aus
sachsen anhalt zu zweifelhaften ruhm ja
ganz genau doch nun droht der jungen
frau knast was theresa w alles
angestellt haben soll und was ihr haus
glawe und ein domina studio damit zu tun
haben schauen sie mal selbst
straff 6 statt bußgeld mit sex clips in
regionalzügen der deutschen bahn
verdiente sich zugbegleiterin theresa
wie heimlich geld dazu
schwarzfahrer wurden hart ran genommen
und dabei gefilmt
bis die schmuddel drews der 36-jährigen
auf logan den job war sie damit los doch
ihren kunden bleibt sie treu heute
bestraft die porno schaffnerin
schwarzfahrer professionell im leipziger
sm bahnhof wie lange sie noch die
peitsche schwingen darf ist unklar denn
inzwischen ermitteln polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft in zwei bundesländer
gegen sie
uns so geschaltet ist jetzt
bild-reporter thilo scholtyseck er hat
teresa us geschichte recherchiert thilo
du bist ja schon seit jahren an ihr dran
was ist theresa für eine person was
kannst du uns zu ihr sagen
und morgen ja die theresa wie ist schon
eine ganz besondere junge frau sie ist
sehr extrovertiert sie präsentiert sich
im netz mit ihren bildern mit ihren
clips und was ungewöhnlich ist als sie
noch zugbegleiterin war hat sie unter
ihrem klarnamen auch auf ground
frauenplattform leute gesucht die geld
schon club geben die die ihr eigenes
domina studio finanzieren sollten das
war sehr ungewöhnlich war der stiefvater
ist hier ein lokalpolitiker in
sachsen-anhalt er sei überall im landtag
das war für die familie leicht belastend
aber sie hat sich da einfach ausgeliebt
und will das ebenso verrückt sie mag
ihre auftritte
stiefvater hat sogar mal eine
pressekonferenz für sie organisierte
kamen journalisten da wurde ja fall
dargelegt warum sie ein rechtsstreit mit
den
bahnunternehmen
einfach wollte sie sich da mal
rechtfertigen jahr der öffentlichkeit
was ja eigentlich wirklich verrückt ist
ansonsten sie gibt jan gefährt ganz
schnell und das ist das problem ist hat
sie schon seit jahren immer wieder
probleme mit der justiz hat sie wird
erhöht wenn sie geblitzt wird und dann
fährt sie weiter und dann hat sich
strafverfahren meistens am hals wegen
fahren ohne führerschein jedoch warum im
mittel denn jetzt die staatsanwaltschaft
ganz aktuell gegen theresa w ja aber es
gibt jetzt neue vorwürfe mittlerweile
kommen solche sachen dazu wie hehlerei
sie hat dieser bestimmung vor vier
wochen in leipzig als sie versucht hat
einen kaminofen zu verkaufen mit ihren
haussklaven
dieser kaminofen den hatte sie
offensichtlich ihren stiefvater
gestohlen der agenturen gewählt die
polizei cham hat das den ofen
sichergestellt und dabei stellte sich
dann auch noch heraus dass noch mehr auf
einer geldstrafe gegen sie und sie hatte
großes glück er nach der festnahme rief
sie jemanden der kommen kann tatsächlich
und hat die 1800 euro bezahlten hat sie
da ausgelöst was sagt sie selbst zu den
vorwürfen hat sich die reserve schon
öffentlich zu den anschuldigungen
geäußert
sie hatte schon wiederholt geäußert und
es ist dann meistens so dass die schuld
bei anderen liegt es ist immer ein
ex-freund der jubel will oder ja sie
selber sieht die schuld bei sich also
das ist zu den aktuellen unserer
aktuellen vorwürfen da kommt noch betrug
dazu da sagte jetzt nichts mehr aber das
was sie am meisten belastet die sache
mit dem auto fahren mit diesen
schwarzfahren weil sie ja immer wieder
ohne führerschein erwischt und da sagt
sich schlichtweg das sind einfach nur
leute die mit günstig sind das nachsagen
aber aber sie bezahlen ihre strafen und
nur bei straßen wird jetzt nicht mehr
bleiben bei geldstrafen diesmal droht
ihr wegen der wiederholung dann
wahrscheinlich auch meine haftstrafe
vielen dank thilo scholtyseck